here are a few tips for creating a text
campaign first you really want to
highlight what makes your company stand
out
why are you unique include prices
promotions or other exclusives people
often do searches because they want to
make a decision about something now if
they're trying to decide what to do with
their dog weather away let's help them
make that choice don't forget a call to
action tell the customers what they can
do to get what you're offering like sign
ups add a book your first visit things
like that don't forget about your
keywords be sure to include your
keywords in your ad to show how relevant
you are to their search for example if
they're searching for or an extra income
our headline could be earn income by
dog-sitting
we're going to talk about keywords more
later in the lesson your ad needs to
match your landing page you want to make
sure that customers can easily find what
they're looking for and see the
relevance of your at all so this
relevancy will help you later with your
SEO performance
it'll help influence your ad placement
think about it from your customers
perspective if they want to come to your
site because you're offering a two month
free subscription don't make them look
for it get them in and hooked right away
and finally experiment run a few
different ad groups and different types
of ads see which one's perform the best
you can track your messaging and figure
out what ads they're going to be best
for you and your customers okay now I
want you to create your own campaign
fill in the blanks below for an ad that
you would run for your own company